(upbeat music)
- Guys, how's it going?
Today we're on set with Kelly and Ryan.
Unfortunately, Ryan is
not here, but that's okay
because we are making something very,
very, very, very special,
come check it out.
I'm doing a cooking demo on how
to make Margherita cupcakes.
Can you guys believe it?
Me, cooking, demo, in the
same sentence, and on TV?
(upbeat music)
I just asked them, how do they feel
about juggling on the show
and they said they're into it!
So I need to do a little
practice, just to make sure.
Okay, I'm putting you guys
on the spice rack right now.
(crowd talking)
It's just practicing (laughs).
(slow music)
(applause)
- Everybody get up, it's gonna squirt.
We don't have a knife
here but if you did--
- We do!
- Oh, you do?
Okay great, I'm gonna show you something
that I just learned, okay?
So if you take a knife (laughter), okay,
and then you cut down the middle
you get twice as much
juice, it really allows you
to really juice the heck out of your lime.
- Margherita cupcakes.
- I wanna know where
the Tequila frosting is.
- I think that's it.
- We didn't finish that yet, movie magic.
- We gotta finish that.
- [Male host] Good stuff, yummy, yummy.
- Cheers, cheers!
- So we just finished up at Kelly and Ryan
and I'm so excited, I'm gonna put a link
in the description where
you guys can go like,
share, comment and make
sure you guys leave
some amazing comments
and say that you think
that my dessert deserves to win
the 10 thousand dollars for charity.
So check it out, but now we're in the car
and I'm heading up to have
lunch with Johnny Cupcakes.
He's my absolute favorite
and let's go do that now.
(slow music)
- Lots of action, lots of action.
- We just went to a salad place.
What was that salad place called?
- Sweetgreen.
- I always see Sara go there
and Sara may be joining us
very shortly, she's really
cool, my friend Sara.
- Can we trick her, does she like tricks,
or is she sensitive?
- I think, no, I don't
think she's sensitive.
She might be sensitive but I think she can
be tricked so this is gonna be exciting.
- I carry around magic
tricks with me all the time.
- Do you guys remember the one time
that I had a cockroach
in my house and the ones
that I still have in my
house, that's your fault.
I was like, "what is this?"
So we're having a nice little
lunch here in the park.
This is Madison Square Park.
Neither one of us live
here, you're visiting.
- I'm visiting from Boston.
- Oh, this is Johnny Cupcakes, by the way.
- Hey.
- If you guys didn't know.
(car horn)
You're so big!
I'm sure this is very, very clean.
So, what are you doing in New York?
Do you know, is it a secret?
- I'm giving a talk.
- Cool.
- I give talks, I just hand
them away like little trinkets.
- You're like, "here we go,
I've got some presents for you."
But yeah, we're gonna have a nice salad.
I'm enjoying the park,
the weather's great,
I just did Kelly and Ryan,
unfortunately Ryan was not there.
- Ry guy, he's a busy man, does
all the radio in the world.
- He does, I don't know
how he does everything,
like I can barely wake
up and shower and Ryan,
by that point, has already
done a TV show, a radio show.
- He looks young, too.
- He does.
- He knows the secret of
life, him and Pharrell.
♪ Well I should probably
warn you I'll be just fine ♪
- Can I show you a photo
of my pride and joy?
- [Justine] Is this a vlog moment or no?
- [Sara] Are you about to show me a baby?
- [Justine] Oh my god, are you kidding me?
- I was expecting a baby
and I got that, I can't.
- I was like wait, is this
something I should vlog
or is this like an
inappropriate, like wait.
- Wait, actually this is something you
should probably get, give me one moment.
- Oh, he's about to do
a magic trick for us.
- I'm already really stoked
on our new friendship.
- (Laughs) You're gonna love this.
- [Sara] Okay, I'm excited.
- Three, two, one.
(excited yelling)
- [Sara] No!
- [Brett] That was amazing.
- Alright, see this little container?
In Japan nobody litters so
they'll take their cigarettes
and they'll put them out
in these pocket ash trays
that they carry around.
So I'm gonna put this cigarette in here.
Push close.
- [Sara] What?
- [Justine] What?
- [Sara] What's that little
teeny, tiny cigarette?
- It belonged to the little
baby hand, I don't know.
- Oh, bring it, oh my god, wow.
- I don't know.
- Johnny has inspired me
so much with my business,
I know everything about this guy
just 'cause it's such a good story
and I knew that his first
business was being a magician.
- It's true.
- That's what he's doing,
showing us how it's done.
- My first time on stage was
actually doing a magic show
when I was little, yes,
and let me tell you
how crappy that was.
(upbeat music)
Sara's boosting with another
Boosted board on her back
because she wants me to boost with her.
Does she know what she's
getting herself into?
- No cars, in the middle of that.
- Yeah, this is cool, wow.
What am I doing, this is dangerous,
I see you and Casey doing this
and I'm like, "no, no, no."
- She's done it before though.
- Not in New York, are you crazy?
- But look at how open this is!
- This is not open and not...
- It's gonna be you.
- That's me, that's me, that's me.
What are you doing,
why are you driving me?
Are you driving me?
- Let's see how, look,
you got the balance.
- I'm doing it!
- Look at her go, wow, I
don't think she can stop now.
She just like crash
into like the bike rack.
Going backwards.
- I gotta do it again.
- [Sara] See, that wasn't too bad.
- Like it was (mumbles)
- [Brett] Alright, this
is what you're doing next.
- You gotta do this one next.
- I just mastered this.
- Come on.
- No, shut up.
- [Nef] You gotta know how to bike
- Okay.
- Ah, she's in there, come on, let's go.
- [Sara] Oh my gosh.
- It's just like mounting a horse, suit.
So you put one in, boom,
put your leg right over.
- Oh my gosh, how do I stop,
I'm scared, I'm scared!
- Wait, I'm gonna hold
you, I'm holding on, look.
- Okay, okay, oh my god.
- (mumbles) right here, back leg.
- Okay, back, I don't, don't
let me go, don't let me go.
Hello, hello, hello, I'm
flying so I'm tall, I think.
This is so cool.
Okay, I'm gonna stop now.
My name's Justine, nice to meet you.
- It was, yeah.
- What's your name?
- Nef.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Brett] How was that?
- It was so great, thank you!
- You got it, any time.
- High five!
- I'm at Instagram, Nef537.
- Okay, I'll tag you.
That's amazing.
- [Brett] What was more
fun, the Boosted board
or the double-deck bike?
- Boosted is fun, this was
super unexpected, I will say.
So, should we discuss what happened?
I mean, I just got on
a bike with a stranger
and I was terrified
about the Boosted board.
- So, she was so scared to get on this
and then a stranger rolls up on, like,
a double-decker bike,
he stops, jokes around,
"hey, you wanna get on this?"
Justine was like "sure,
yeah, let's do it."
- And he's like, "wait, do you
actually not know how to ride a bike?"
I'm like, "I don't know,
we're gonna find out!"
(slow music)
Now we're to coffee, I
haven't had a coffee for
like seven hours and it's
really, really killing my vibe.
- Can't go more than one hour.
- Is that coffee on tap,
or is that actual...
- I don't know.
- It's cold brew.
- Cold brew on tap, hello, that's fancy!
Look at all these treats!
Do I get the cold brew
or do I get the tea?
Okay, well, actually, so,
Sara's getting the cold brew
which means I'm gonna take a sip of hers,
she doesn't know it yet,
and I'm gonna get the tea.
So this is all gonna work out great.
- I got the cold brew,
it's actually really good,
you can taste it.
- Sara left and I forgot to try her coffee
and I'm so upset about it.
Is the coffee good, have you had it?
- The coffee's really good but
this is my first time trying
the Serendipitea, it's very
good as well, it's delicious.
- So if I asked you guys
what my favorite color is
or was or a color combination,
you guys know it's camo
and specifically purple camo.
- So, yeah, I'm a daily
vlogger here in New York City,
I own a clothing company
and a skateboard company
called Fortune Skateboards
and I was showing Justine
some of the graphics and
the first one she caught
her eye on was this purple camo board.
So I'm gonna send her two.
- I can't wait guys, I'm so
excited, I'm freaking out.
And you guys know I'm
not the best skateboarder
but it is something that I
actually really do like doing.
- [Man] Oh, god, are you okay (laughs)?
- But then I get made fun of when I go
to the skate park 'cause
I'm like the old lady
that has like, a helmet and all the pads.
I gotta be safe, guys.
- Safety first, but
I'm gonna send you two.
One for the wall and one for you to ride.
- Okay, cool, I'm so excited, thank you!
Well I'm exhausted.
Today was such a long
day but I had so much fun
in New York, I really wanted to get
some really cool cinematic shots
to do some really cool B roll
and add some really cool music
under it but I ran out of time.
And I'm heading back to
LA very, very shortly
so I will see you guys back there.
I had so much fun hanging out with Kelly
and all of the rest of
my friends in this video.
It was so great, I'll see you guys later
and that's it, bye!
(soft music)